I Got a Job!
Hey, Mom! Guess what!
Abbott Laboratories called me and said I got the job!
I'm on cloud nine, Mom!
You know how much I wanted this job.
And, believe it or not, they are going to pay me 30,000 dollars a year!
That's a lot of money for a person who just graduated from college!
I can't believe I get to do what I enjoy, and get paid for it.
I'm so lucky.
I really feel good about myself now.
I was feeling down because it seemed like nobody wanted to hire me.
What are you talking about?
Why wouldn't anybody want to hire a talented person like you?
If I were an HR person, I would hire you in a heartbeat.
You have a wonderful personality,...
...your GPA is good,...
...you are good at what you do.
You are a perfect candidate!
And I'm not just saying it because you're my son.
I'm serious!
Anyway, I'm excited about what you've done, son.
I'm sure your Dad will be, too.
Let me give him a call.
Oh, and we should celebrate!
I will throw a big party for you.
How about that?